this week I discovered that in her
iCloud files she had so many pictures of
her with different
men brothers and sisters just imagine
for a second that you give £10 in
donation and that £10 is used to buy
food or bricks or whatever to help the
people in Gaza but then just imagine
this amazing de that you want to do but
we turn it into a moneymaking machine
how the W is exactly that they take your
money and the money that we are going to
put in in this W this building and every
single time the money generated from
that W that building is going to go to
our Palestinian brothers and sisters for
the next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150 years
and this will be a form of
true I myself will be donating for that
inshallah click the link below and
donate may Allah subhana bless and
preserve you
guys brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well insh this
is another episode with uh me and my
wife uh that's not what the show is
called it's just I'm just you guys on
here my wife Salam
Alum how you doing hope you're well inah
thanks for being here and we look
forward to your contributions because
it's very very important to have a
female perspective on matters that I
might miss it might go of my head so as
you know if there's anything you believe
that I say wrong please feel free to
correct me aldah um you know um what do
I say wisdom is the Lost Property of the
believer and he takes it wherever he
finds it so like I said before I'm not
infallible um and yes in if anything
that you think I'm wrong in uh which I L
of sister believe I'm wrong in you can
voice inallah and there'll be no
consequences you can just blink twice
inallah if you are in danger uh in
brother sister Jokes Aside inah I'm here
with my wife we are going to be doing a
reaction video the reason we're doing
this brother sister I have the bit of
trip show which we talk about these
issues but some with my wife obviously
there's things that she can say to me
maybe the s in the panel can't may Allah
bless him in and if you guys want watch
the bit show really really help I
believe will help your household
inshallah we discuss many other things
now when I saw this video here guys I
was like
the comments was even more crazy and
this just shows again this is what I
mean but there's a absolute double
standard this happens a lot with sisters
going to be honest tell me if I'm wrong
the double standards it's crazy and I'm
going to tell you if I'm wrong please
correct me please correct me we're going
to watch for ourself okay here's a
situation of a man who marries this
sister the Muslim I'm assuming because
this arrang marriage and he finds out
things after now I'm assuming he went
through his phone whatever it is for the
matter but
we're going to talk about that so here's
a video we're going to react with my
wife and then after that my wife if you
guys are new to this she has a little
whiteboard that I bought her there we go
she going to express it through there
that's out of her choice not that she's
not allowed to speak she prefers not to
or to the minimalist so she wants to
express herself through the Whiteboard
if there's something she disagrees if
she wants to elaborate I've told her she
can vocalize it or she can tell me in my
ear and I would repeat the best of my
ability inshallah so here's a video are
you ready you sure okay
I found that my wife was sleeping around
before we got married it's an arranged
marriage and her mom and her family
acted like they were the most Pious and
religious people possible this week I
discovered that in her iCloud files she
had so many pictures of her with
different men in bed in her apartment in
colge but he's saying she never told me
about this and I have yet to confront
her we've only been married 6 months and
I'm like losing it I don't know what to
do but I just feel angry that I've been
lied to and that she put on a fake face
there's a screenshot in there of her
texting some other guy and saying that
she wanted to have his baby
Allah she is disrespectful she's trying
why are you doing this to the brother
like goodness and this screenshot was
only Taken 3 months prior to our wedding
day okay you saw that for yourself yeah
okay now there's a few things that I
just want to point out because I just
believe it's fair okay then tell me if
I'm wrong number one the reaction of the
sister the sister on the left I don't
know yeah she's like oh why would you do
that to her brother I just and I know
it's not intentional I she not from a
malicious place but I'm just going to
reverse the whole role I'm going to
reverse everything and I just want to
see if a man did that how the Dynamics
would be okay now firstly would you
agree or disagree with him going through
her
phone write it down in the meantime I'm
going to express myself number one as
men and I make this very clear even in
my my marriage alhamdulillah that do not
go through each other's phones why
brothers and sisters especially men look
like they say ignorance is bliss don't
go through your wife's phone number one
and we've done a whole episode on this
on the bit of Truth don't go through
your wife's phone because it can be that
there are pictures of her sisters there
pictures of her friends there without
hijab or whatever for that matter that's
number one number two there might be
private things you discusses it might be
you know how woman are sometimes they
can be emotional you've upset her she's
on her menes or whatever and she wants
to one second and she wants to basically
Express maybe she says something about
you but she doesn't mean it you see
that's going to upset her worst in which
case scenario which is what you might
see something from her past that could
destroy your marriage because for us men
we have a that there are certain pills
we cannot swallow and I'm going to come
to you how I would have reacted this me
personally Ali not Islam this is Ali but
here's what my wife said he shouldn't be
going through her phone I agree there we
go someone say you're medip PL there we
go yeah there we go I agree as well
shouldn't be going through the pH her
phone you should not and neither should
she be going through your phone cuz the
same things apply vice versa however
however we can say that was a sin he
should not done it he done it he found
out Allah subhana T you want to call it
whatever like export whatever you want
to call it yeah now do you want to read
the comments check this out are you
ready first first of all what she did
before marriage is not her husband's
business nearly 1,000 likes
yeah her parents might be religious you
can't say it's her parents' fault they
might not even know what their
daughter's been doing okay why is he
going through her iCloud messages and
pictures her past is her hers and she's
only answerable to Allah she chose to
marry you and her past has nothing to do
with you this is why men have double
standards we're about to find out bro
married the town bike oh okay where are
people in the comments defending her why
are people in the comments defending her
yeah it's insane how many people always
rush to support of the woman and start
bashing the man blindly no matter what
somebody wrote divorce yeah now another
one what about a guy who sleeps around
before marriage valid she'll never
change she's
got
now mainly you see females writing down
what what are females doing mainly
defending her now I want to reverse the
roles please don't kill me in the
process what I'm going to do is the
following now in that situation brothers
and sisters for all of these people are
saying this yeah now me
personally if that was to happen to me
that is a pill that I will not and
cannot swallow may Allah forgive me if I
found that out for me it is an instant
end
because number one it's a scam her P
come be a p no one saying he has no
right to call her names like oh you are
a h o e and you are a s l u t and you no
no no no no that is Haram you are not
allowed to say that you she may have
repented even if she didn't you are not
allowed to say that however am I right
or wrong to say that he has a right to
divorce now sister going to say well
it's her past now let's reverse the
roles now tell me from wrong my wife and
my dear sisters let's change this up a
bit let's put some add some spice let's
add some herbs in this you know some
Masala yeah some salt yeah salt B now
what if what if she found out that he
has a second wife or should we say three
months or six months into the marriage
he says I want to I want a second wife
yeah okay and by the way you got the
back you can write the back as well yeah
cuz my wife is writing a PO right now
yeah so what if he she found out and
went through his eyecloud would you guys
be saying oh why did she go through Z
you be like no you go girl you go girl
woo you go go slay the day babe tell me
if I'm wrong yeah you're laughing at me
yeah so the point is what you say oh Dam
rash she did he went he didn't went and
did what it's not Haram it's Halal oh
and what if she done a post and said by
the way I have chosen to divorce him you
girls will be like celebration yes
divorce is back side hold on a second
what happened to not judging him because
a man judges a Woman by her past and a
woman judges a man by his future if she
okay halfway we got stopped ladies first
a woman should be ex a woman shouldn't
be exposing her sin especially if she's
repeated it repented at her own accord
she can tell her husband if she wants
but wouldn't advise as is exposing the
sins correct so by the way have you
heard my second wife that I just
mentioned I need you to comment on that
if it's possible yeah correct you
shouldn't expose your sins unless a man
says look this is what I'm looking for I
would like a virgin wife then you try to
divert that by saying okay you know
we're not compatible okay that is his
right but the point I'm seeing is the
following my dear sisters and brothers
is that if the roles were reversed if
the roles were reversed for a man he
cares about his wife's past a woman
cares about his future meaning is there
going to be another woman is he going to
get married again why is it that when a
man rejects a woman because she has a
past and that's what matters to him he
is blamed as how do you judge him Only
God can judge you Etc judgment is
different he cannot accuse and call the
names but he has a right to say no thank
you not for me but if a woman was to be
getting to know a man and he said I plan
on get married again not a single one of
you sisters will come and say oh she's
um she's wrong for that no you say damn
right than good why the double standards
am I wrong please I want you to please
address that if I'm wrong yeah and the
same thing he found out about her past
and decided to maybe end the marriage
why is he wrong now personally I would
say if there's kids involved Etc ask
Allah subhana to Aid you and help you to
overcome it with this situation it is so
close and this is the reason why it can
be it can be worse for a woman who
commits Z why not in the Shar the Shar
is the same the punishment is the same
the capital punishment is the same in
the Hereafter it's the same however she
could have easily ascribed that child
that she said I want to have his babies
to his to her current husband this is
why a woman is capable of doing that and
a man is not that's why Z being done by
a woman can be consequentially in the
sense of the world be
greater tell me if I'm wrong polygamy
should be discarded prior prior marriage
so a woman is aware especially if it's a
deal breaker for the Sisters a woman
should have a choice a polygamy and
choice is not F I agree but the point
I'm saying is the following what if this
was reversed and that she he found she
found out that he has a second wife or
wants a second wife would anyone or when
she went through his phone and found out
that he has a second wife would the
sisters will be be as
outraged yes or no please I'm asking you
I'm ask ask my wife this question listen
to me again did you hear me if the rol
were reversed if the row were reversed
and the sister went through her his
eyecloud find found that he has a second
wife or got a second wife and wanted
divorce would any sister blame her or
would they back her up so would they
blame her or would they back her up I
want to hear I want to see your answer
I'm very intrigued but again look Allah
says in the Quran speak the truth even
if it's against yourself yeah what will
the sister say they'll back her up and I
appreciate and value your honesty thank
you may Allah bless and preserve you
that is the point I'm saying guys let's
just be consistent a sister has a right
to reject a brother if he wants to get
married again that is her Islamic
choice however again the same thing with
a man if he hears that his wife has
slept with 10 different men he has a
right to say not for me you cannot blame
him or have a go at him that's why
that's the double standards that I
wanted to point out and brothers and
sisters in these situation it is really
hard for a man when he finds out his
wife has a past and it's really hard for
a woman if she finds out that his his
her husband wants a second wife or third
wife or fourth wife for that matter
however with Allah all things are
possible ask Allah subhana wa tala and
say oh my Lord this is heavy on my heart
this is destroying me Shan's giving me
waswasa to the man this why this that
guy that guy did this to your wife or
the man oh look he's going to he's got
married again he doesn't love you ask
Allah sub's guide for Allah all things
are possible andah tal talking about
divorce Allah says in the Quran if you
fear me Allah will give you a away out
from places you can never imagine
anything else you'd like to
say no I thank you for your
contributions may Allah bless you for
your honesty brothers and sisters
inshallah again this is a new series
that I started um talking about this
issue because we don't want divorces to
happen I don't want divorce to happen my
wife doesn't want it we hear this
stories left right center and again I'm
not here to show you my lifestyle my
private nothing do with you I'm only
having my wife's contributions and at
with her permission that I've asked
because she does not want to be on
social media at all and I believe it's
very important she's my wife who Am who
else am I going to bring here okay the
point is that she agreed to come and
voice opinions via the Whiteboard
inshallah may Allah bless and preserve
everyone's marriage and protect our
marriages from harm may Allah subhana wa
tala allow us to be reunited in Jenna
with my wife you guys with your wife or
your wives whatever you want to do for
that matter yeah I mean inshallah till
next time sisters if you would like to
us to react to more situations
pertaining to marital issues ETC we
would inshallah be uh honored to do that
inshah and yeah this this is s far I'm
going to carry on if I see people
benefit from it uh but again I can
change my mind and all of these videos
might be deleted for whatever reason in
but yeah that's all I want to say